hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar titled enhanced rapid target
identification by NGS for vaccine
development this webinar is part of the
ongoing coronavirus virtual webinar
series
I am Kaylee Bach of labyrinth and I will
be your moderator for today met today's
educational web seminar is presented by
labyrinth and sponsored by thermo Fisher
Scientific to learn more visit thermo
Fisher now let's get started before we
begin I would like to remind everyone
that this event is interactive we
encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as like
during the presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a question box
and click send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the part engaged if you have trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen as a reminder
this presentation is educational and
offers free continuing education credits
click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits I now present today's speaker
Chris Kinross Chris Kinross graduated a
neuroscience from Allegheny College
where she investigated the molecular
role of stress and aging on brain
resilience her focus on NGS development
has contributed to the democratization
and simplification of NGS technology for
a complete biography on your speaker
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen Chris you may now
begin your presentation
this is certainly a topic that's near
and dear to us because as a company
Armen truly is to enable our customers
and the scientists in the world to make
the world healthier cleaner and safer at
our core we are all scientists and this
is our purpose and so we feel like
sharing thoughts on this might be
helpful for the community the first
stage of vaccine development is
discovery this is where we identify the
actual disease the next generation
sequencing or NGS for short is typically
the primary method used in this stage
vaccines which have ballots using
specific strange and so the goal in this
stage is to identify each of the
pathogenic strains of that disease
understand the rate of evolution of the
disease and identify if it's forming new
strain or is fairly stable so the type
of sequencing used to monitor mutations
will depend upon the mutational rate of
the virus corona virus for example
mutates fairly slowly about once a month
on average and so the most efficient way
to understand how the virus is spreading
or evolving is to use whole genome
sequencing because this allows us to map
that entire genome the next stages of
preclinical development and clinical
development will be the focus of other
case studies in this series we invite
you to review those studies as well
because it will allow you to follow the
entire process
Maxine development is often an iterative
process with a sense of urgency so if we
consider one current example the novel
virus kovat 19 the current viral
outbreak as of march 2020 timeframe we
can look back to December of 2019 when
people in Wuhan China began to fall ill
that illness has been rapidly sequence
and characterized in nearly every
country in the world as of March 2020 an
example of the speed of characterization
provided by NGS techniques can be seen
in Nigeria on the 27th of February
Nigeria confirmed its first case of
kovat 19 at the infectious disease
Hospital in Java and mangas on the 1st
of March the clinical specimen was sent
to Redeemers University in Nigeria and
the Center for human biology and
genomics the Nigerian Institute of
Medical Research for sequencing and
molecular characterization the genome
was published on github on March 4th the
turnaround time from sample receipts of
sequence generation was three days the
speed offered by NGS techniques
accelerates timelines for vaccine
development by providing a clear genomic
signature as well as insight into that
rate of mutation so for example the
first Brazilian sequence closely
resembles the samples that were
sequenced in Germany but the second
Brazilian genome is actually more
similar to the genome sequenced in the
United States comparison of genomic
profiles enables study of different
viral strains so that we can select the
virulence or the most aggressive strains
the target for vaccine development so
the colibri portfolio from in vitro gen
Thermo Fisher Scientific is really based
on a simple mission it's time for NGS
library props to evolve and one area in
which older library prep kits are
lacking is in the use of clear liquids
and clear tubes without any in processed
feedback at the end of one the two days
of the bench you find out if you made
libraries this approach wastes time as
well as very precious samples that could
fail and need to be reprocessed
again assuming that you even have
sufficient material remaining complete
lack of feedback when working with clear
liquids and clear tubes is one of those
problems which we address here so you
can see a schematic in the manual which
shows how the tracking dyes indicate
success
the video shows actual dyes being mixed
you can see where the reagents aren't
properly mixed by the distinct red and
green layers you can see proper mixing
with the transition to purple these
tracking dyes allow you to save those
samples that would have otherwise been
lost because you can confirm proper
technique by your robot or by the
technician at each step these tracking
dyes also allow you to move more quickly
with higher success rates compared to
older library perhaps technology because
you can visually confirm proper
technique at each step you don't need to
go back and mix everything again you can
see immediately if the step was
performed accurately and just keep going
so when it's 30 minutes into your
library prep protocol which only takes
an hour and a half how do you know if
it's working so with these Calibri kits
you get the feedback at every step the
other area where Calibri library prep
kits are offering improvement is to
reduce the needs of source reagents and
materials from multiple vendors this has
been a big problem with the Cova 19 test
kit development and finding supplies
from multiple vendors this library prep
kit includes everything you need a
simple school it has adapters PCR
reagents if that's appropriate cleanup
beads
it even has their field this lets you
focus on the science and just keep going
so while multiple sequencing methods for
Illumina systems are supported by the
colibri portfolio in this discussion
we're actually going to focus on two
methods which are whole genome
sequencing which we use to assemble
novel genomes as well as monitor the
mutation rate of diseases but also on
three-times mRNA sequencing because this
is used to understand changes in host
gene expression changes in pathogen gene
expression but also how the two interact
so differences in gene expression
people who become seriously ill in
response to a disease compare the people
who experience only mild symptoms can be
really important for vaccine development
so let's start with whole genome
sequencing here you can see a summary of
the various details for DNA that's been
physically sheared this option is
available for genomes of all sizes so it
can be used to assemble the genome of a
novel virus but also of the person
infected with that virus for RNA viruses
that have been reverse transcribed into
double-stranded cDNA these kits are a
big improvement over transpose omec prop
kits because these kits are really fast
the libraries are generated in about an
hour and a half so we offer options for
physically sheared as well as
automatically shared DNA and they both
provide the same sensitivity of
detection for copy number variants or
variant calling from very low samples
all the way up to very high samples you
get the entire genome which is a little
bit different from transpose omec
methods and it's been thoroughly tested
with the greatest samples such as FFPE
the DNA tests are extremely consistent
and this is across different users so it
minimizes batch effects but it also
allows you to have consistent
performance from low inputs to high
input of DNA so this consistency is
unique to the colibri kit and what it
means is that you get the same variant
calls in the same genomic coverage from
a small amount say from blood as from
larger amounts what you might get from
buccal swabs or from nasal swabs you are
limited by the amount of family you can
collect and therefore you can collect
what you have rather than turn away
potentially very valuable samples
because there wasn't enough DNA in them
achieving coverage of the entire genome
is a really critical aspect of vaccine
development and this just isn't possible
from transfuse emic sharing methods
transfers omics sharing methods rely on
near random insertion of transfer zone
complexes throughout the genome you may
have heard of this method referred to as
tag notation
the one drawback of tag mentation is at
the end of the genome camping sequence
and this limits the amount of
information available from your
sequencing data
the biggest advantage of transpose omec
methods is that they're really fast
typically about an hour and a half but
for the same amount of time roughly an
hour and a half with the colibri kids
you actually get the entire genome so
using a sharing and ligation approach
the entire genome and politicus is
converted into libraries on Illumina
platform and assembled using standard
informatics tool nothing special needed
because you get the entire genome
whether it's a small genome similar to a
virus or a larger genome such as human
or bat if you're looking into animal
reservoirs you actually get the complete
information that you're looking for the
DNA gifts have been used already with
really badly degraded samples and very
low inputs of those degraded samples dr.
Carlos was OVA at Mazurek University and
humble use these kits to investigate
circulating tumor cells in peripheral
blood from liquid biopsy research
samples the samples were obtained with
consent from people living with chronic
lymphocytic leukemia she compared
results from tumor cells against results
from buccal swabs that were sequenced on
a next week 5:50 system from Illumina
you can see here the red and blue line
which reference copy number variation
which were observed from tumor DNA and
cell free DNA using this kit the results
are really high sensitivity of detection
from the liquid biopsy research samples
at most sequencing depth of roughly 5 to
6 X coverage these kits are extremely
sensitive dr. Clem ovo went on to
investigate if the colibri kits are able
to detect differences between research
samples from patients who were currently
undergoing treatment compared to
patients who had not yet begun treatment
or were not eligible for treatment this
type of test indicates that if the
library prep kit has a high enough
accuracy to reliably differentiate
between different experimental
conditions so a similar example
vaccine development would be to
distinguish between strains of a
particular virus with that same
sensitivity
dr. Cole Evo was able to reliably
distinguish between samples from
patients who are undergoing treatment
compared to samples from patients who
were not able to access treatment the
sequence and depth of these libraries is
very low it's only 5 to 6 X coverage and
it was also performed on a next week
5:50 system from Illumina the results
indicate that there's really high GC
fidelity which accurately represents the
initial sample in resulting sequencing
data so this solves this problem of
garbage in garbage out which you put
into the kit you will actually see in
your sequencing data so we talked about
two methods for sequencing or vaccine
development other big advancement in NGS
being used in vaccine development right
now is 3-prime mRNA sequencing this
method provides gene expression data
from as little as 2 to 5 million reads
and so it can be sequenced quickly and
expensively but also have the sequencing
data analyzed very quickly so when speed
is absolutely critical and you need to
retain all of the information these
options are great gene expression
patterns can provide insights into why
one group of humans might experience
this sniffles when they are inflicted
with the novel virus compared to much
more serious outcomes such as
hospitalization or even worse gene
expression data provides new insights
when coupled with genomic data from
whole genome sequencing do you permit
development of vaccines subtypes that
reduce side effects and boost efficacy
and to be able to do that very quickly
the 3-prime method works through a
series of rather clever blocking all
egos as well as choice of enzymes that
result in high coverage of the 3-prime
under the transcript without covering
the rest of the transcript the what this
allows you to do is analyze the full
difference in gene expression much more
quickly and affordably without investing
in very detailed and expensive analysis
pipeline
the low number of reads for 3-prime
sequencing which can be as low as two
million reads per sample gives you
flexibility and choice of instrument and
speed so you can choose to run many
small batches on a low throughput system
such as the mini seek system from
Illumina or you can batch up a large
amount of samples and run them all
together very inexpensively I'm a nova
seek system also from Illumina the data
quality across the systems is so similar
that your projects become a lot more
flexible compared to a method such as
whole transcriptome sequencing because
other methods such as whole
transcriptome sequencing you would need
30 to 60 million reads for samples to
get the same information so this starts
to limit your choices flexibility using
the 3-prime system also gives you
flexibility in geography so you can run
test locally throughout the region and
you don't have to rely on large
sequencing centers to process your
samples you can actually now generate
data in the field near the source of the
sample very quickly and very
consistently
the suscribe method is already being
used to study infectious disease you can
see here data that was presented by dr.
Nicholas Maness of Tulane University for
Zika samples from primates our new
sequencing previously was too
cost-prohibitive and frankly just
daunting in terms of data analysis and
so dr. Manassas first comparison was
against the gene expression result he
previously had detected by nano string
panels this isn't a perfect comparison
between groups because we tested
pregnant females against males and so
you would expect to see differences in
gene expression but what he was looking
for was depth of information and he
could see in this initial screening that
he received a far richer data set from
three prime and GF sequencing compared
to an ANA string option because he was
with the initial result he went on to
test it more deeply his next test was to
explore ease of data interpretation so
using a very simple in Health pipeline
he was able to visualize metabolic
programming but also to determine
enriched gene sets this was particularly
exciting for him because the colibri
gene expression data sets are far richer
compared to what he has previously been
able to achieve with Manas drying and
they were actually lower cost and so he
announced a few weeks ago that he
intends to use the colibri through time
mRNA kids who began covered 19 viral
studies immediately now that NIH funding
has been released in the United States
data sets for the colibri RNA portfolio
can be analyzed and interpreted using
the genie Alice expression software this
software contains pre-built
analysis pipelines for full
transcriptome sequencing mRNA sequencing
and 3-prime mRNA sequencing from the
colibri portfolio it's designed for
biologists rather than in fermentation
if you'd like to get a demo of this
software
we encourage you to contact jeanne alice
at the email address shown here
the NGS informatics community has been
so good at working together and they
rapidly release tools to access
coronavirus genomes from each region
these databases are available for free
to vaccine developers and researchers of
all flavors and so while Thermo Fisher
Scientific dozens endorse or recommend
any specific analysis package a simple
Google search will yield
extremely valuable options and this will
help you to accelerate and simplify your
informatics because you won't need to
build your own database you can access
with the communities already built
together we support the NGS community
with a rather generous sampling program
you can visit the URL shown here to
request the sample or contact your
thermo Fisher Scientific representative
we'd love to be able to help you so with
that I thank you for you
Thank You Christian rocks for your
informative presentation as a reminder
our speaker will follow up with any
questions you have submitted via email
following this webinar we would also
like to thank lab roots and our sponsor
Thermo Fisher Scientific for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go I'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and more
interesting questions questions we do
not have time for today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration this webcast can be
viewed on-demand through the end of this
year 2001 lab routes will alert you via
email when it's available for replay we
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event until next time
goodbye